hi I'm Barbara Liskov I've been a
professor at MIT since 1972 and I've
done work across a wide range within
computer science including probing
methodology software systems programming
languages and so on
I think we live in the information
age I don't think that those of us
working in computing in the 70s and 80s
really forced saw what was going to
happen how everybody would have access
to computers and the accessing things
over the net the other thing that's
happened recently is the deep learning
that's going on in artificial
intelligence which is allowing all sorts
of things like facial recognition speech
understanding etc and of course this
brings many benefits to people it also
brings across many problems like fake
news and the spread of false information
security problems and so on
I never thought about breaking barriers
I was just very interested in what I was
doing and I just kept going it's funny
though you should ask that question
because when I got my first job as a
programmer there were quite a number of
women doing programming because there
was no computer science education and so
people were being hired from many
different fields if it seemed like they
could do the work so it was better than
probably in terms of proportions not
necessarily better in terms of women
being paid as much as men and so forth
but definitely there were women around
I think we need to consider ethics in
computing and think about what we can do
with software to help solve some of the
problems we have like the and I think
artificial intelligence can help here
you know like the spread of fake fake
news I think that's something we could
tackle I think we could be changing some
of the algorithms that are used to
select what happens but I just think in
general we need to move more ethics into
our community and into our curriculum
and we need to have that be a
consideration and the companies when
they think about what they're doing they
should be thinking about the
ramifications of what they're doing and
how they can make things better